[Music]
let's go to cynthia and fionix arizona
what's up cynthia
hello how you doing i'm good how about
you
i'm okay
all right hey that's as good as we can
do sometimes right what's up yes
so
my question is i'm having trouble with
my daughter so
a quick recap when she was 14
she was going on social media created an
instagram account behind my back because
i already told her she could not have
any social media she was using other
people's phones like family members they
thought that she was playing games but
yet she created this account
talking to some stranger boy
who i think was like an older man type
thing she was
sending inappropriate
pictures to him
he they would call each other talk on
the phone um he would never show his
face only she would show her face so
that's why i think it was like an older
man what kind of inappropriate photos
was she sending
of herself
like topless photos or
essential photos
as a 14 year old
as that 14 year old yes so when um we
caught that took all the phones um told
everybody hey she cannot go on anybody's
phone and she needs to call a family
member you have to dial the phone for
her
so i thought that was cleared now when
she's 15
covet happened they sent
the children home with laptop computers
she started going on the zoom chat rooms
with
you know strangers again
so again took her phone away
i mean took the computer away like we
would have to like okay if you've got to
do school work you got to be around
somebody
so now she's about to be 16 we um
started a new school fresh start
we're telling her like you know what you
cannot be on these um sites anymore
we're gonna give you back your phone
because now you're about to be 16.
okay we're going to start this rash four
days into
school you're back
i call her um i went in her room
and i saw like the laptop underneath her
her blanket when i opened it up she's
chatting again with random people saying
i love you they're boyfriend and
girlfriend i'm like
they're boyfriend and girlfriend i'm
like why are you telling this i was like
who is this person i don't know i just
went to this chat room i'm like how do
you get this chat room because when i
tell you to open it up you never know
the password but now a sudden you
remember it
so i'm just like i don't know what to do
like i don't know why she needs
to keep chatting with these boys these
strangers i don't know what she's
looking for what she needs
i'm asking why she does it i don't know
he said she wants friends you just move
you know you just started this new
school so you start you have friends why
are you always trying to build
relationships online so i don't know
what to do we tried counseling
that was like
she wasn't participating in she said she
doesn't need it it was like
nothing there was no good outcome from
counselors so i don't know what else to
do
man
there's so much here
um yeah
there is and then there's not okay
16 year olds are very smart
and they're very capable
um 15 year olds i've been around some
extremely mature 14 year olds that are
impressive smart fun hilarious
um i was a high school coach and i
coached freshmen and sophomores and they
were awesome i loved being around them
they're they're great they made me laugh
and they're children
they're
children
and
they don't have the emotional regulatory
capacity
in many cases
to
to detach from the need to be seen
to be
attached from a need to be heard and or
at least felt like they're heard to be
seen as special
so
what is happening in your home that this
is where she goes to get that stuff
um
so her father is not in her life okay um
he's been that's about what i need to
know right there that's about yeah right
there okay he's been in and out of her
life um he's been um incarcerated he's
incarcerated now so
they talk here and there like when she
wants to talk to him she'll tell me and
i'll make a visit but it's not often so
she needs she's
again i'm i'm making a lot of leaps here
without talking to her and spending some
time with her but
it's not a surprise to me that she is
her sweet little 14 15 16 year old brain
is wondering every single day
what was so bad about me that dad left
what did i do
and then somebody on an anonymous chat
room says i'll tell you that you're
beautiful
i'll show up and tell you that you have
value
just take your shirt off
and
once that switch gets flipped now we're
in a whole different ball game
because there's a natural
physiological arc to this that gets
circumvented which is why we keep adult
predators away from kids
because once the switch is flipped on
now you've got a whole different ball of
wax dealing with kids who've been
sexualized
and so asking what are you doing
this is this is primal this is in her
soul
i will find some man that will tell me
that i'm gut value and that i'm
beautiful and that i'm not worthless
because the one guy that was supposed to
be here left me
and she's gonna spend a long long time
trying to bridge that gap
okay that's an oversimplified
explanation i'm sure there's more
complexity to it in partridge and pear
tree here's the rub
none of that matters
what matters is
let's pretend there was like an arcade
and you dropped your daughter off of
this arcade with some regularity just a
cool place to hang out and then she told
you hey there's strange men hitting on
me there
and they come and rub my shoulders and
they want me to take my shirt off and
they say nice things about me just feels
uh
and then you were like well
i don't think i'm gonna keep dropping
you off there
and then she sneaks out you find out
she's sneaking out and she's going there
and you go get her
when she turns 16 for her birthday would
you then just take her back and be like
all right make good choices
no
you would never let her go back
you'd call the cops you you would scorch
earth and for some reason when it comes
to
the internet and computers
we think those are different things and
i would say
they are different in that there's way
more predators online than there are in
real life
and what i'll tell you is i've just been
a part of too many investigations over
the past 17 18 19 years working in
colleges with high school and college
kids
that have oh man
it just it's got i've got a rise in me
okay
save your daughter
is what i'm telling you
she's begging you save your daughter
be the adult that doesn't leave her
okay what does that mean
that means i'm going to the school
and saying my kid will not participate
in your laptop program because you have
not provided us any sort of safety
mechanisms that keep kids from getting
into
chat rooms with adult sexual predators
that keep them off the internet that
outside of school stuff and i don't know
how to solve that i don't work i'm not a
programmer that's y'all's problem
right my math textbook didn't have a
special portal that someone would
sexually abuse me when i was a kid
your child does
so as far as i'm concerned you're gonna
give my kid alternative assignments
until y'all figure out how to keep
predators out of my home
okay you see what i'm saying
yes
i reject it because they are failing you
and i would make it pretty direct
and like here's some printouts of the
chats of that my daughter's undergoing
on your school device
this also may mean that in your home
you have to get rid of the internet
and
god that'll be annoying and
uncomfortable
and expensive and just frustrating all
the time
you mean you got to go back to getting
dvds at the library yep
but we're talking about your daughter
of course
we're talking about two more years
and so many times i hear parents are
like i would do anything for my kid i
turn off the internet
i'm not going to take away their cell
phone
do it
do anything
here's one more thing
sending her to counseling
about her
sexting
is not the way to go about that
okay
taking her to counseling with you
because you are looking to heal
and become a stronger
um
woman and a stronger mother
after her husband after her father left
you all together
and you're learning some new skills
that's how you do that
okay because if you take her somewhere
and drop her off and say something's
wrong with you they're gonna fix it
that's that's the declaration of war for
a 15 16 year old bring it then okay
right
if it's hey i realized that dad screwed
us both left
and i um
i'll learn how to love you better
and so i'm not asking you are going to
be a part of that you can sit there in
the room and not say anything but you're
gonna be a part of it
um that's a whole different ballgame and
then you know what she gets to see she
gets to see mom cry she gets to see mom
be sad she gets to see mom
be confused
and then she doesn't feel so crazy
anymore
okay but be the only adult in this young
girl's life that will say i'm not
leaving you and i'm standing up and
dude i absolutely know cynthia
that when you take away all this stuff
and put her on an island
it is gonna be it's gonna be hell on
earth in your home i know that
okay
it's also gonna be hell on earth when
she comes home pregnant
it's gonna be hell on earth when she
comes home and says mom i've got fill in
the blank with stis it's going to be
hell on earth when she when you get a
call from a police department saying hey
we found a bunch of nude photos of your
daughter on some guy's computer
you're just picking your hell on earth
and i'd rather pick the relational one
right because there's light on the other
side of that one
i have a quick question so with her
father being incarcerated
i feel like
i would i feel like okay that's her
father still they should have a
relationship but i just feel like it's
just toxic because
you pick and choose when you want to
call
your your children either he's going to
be either he's going to be consistent
or
he is opting out of his daughter's life
again okay
right even if even if she asks to speak
with him she can let's write letters
okay
okay
okay
um
i need some more guidance on that i have
a strong bent and my my opinion on that
it may not be the right thing i'd want
to talk to someone who's an expert in
those type of relationships
what i do know sitting here is that
inconsistency from adults to children
makes children go crazy
because they think they're the reason
there's inconsistency
right or when dad skips a skips uh some
sort of meeting or some sort of phone
call or some sort of face time
they assume huh
must have been something else more
important than me
and the kid doesn't know that dad's in
solitary or that they just did a
lockdown and they took away all the
privileges kid doesn't know that
right um so the kid just absorbs it all
and makes it their fault
and so
letters can always be written
there can always and you can also hold a
letter right you can touch it and you
can read it again and you can read it
again and you can read it again
but if dad's playing games i'm not
having that
that's how i feel but then i get like
i get
you know like torn well
i don't want the courts like he's is he
gonna take me to court and make this
ugly but i'm like you probably wouldn't
because he's listen
he's made it ugly
you're trying you're trying to polish a
turd it's a mess there's not a way to
make this not not ugly
okay right he left y'all whatever he did
he left you hindra
and if he wants to take you to court
then okay i'll go to court then
okay
um i think this is a conversation best
had with your counselor that you're
going to get with you and your daughter
okay okay and letting her know this is
mostly for you but you she's coming
along with you because your counselor is
going to know you and know her and be
able to say hey i think we need to stop
the calls
often in these moments i do know this
time around the calls escalates
behavioral issues with kids especially
teenagers
to call time right after the call with
dad escalation time right before the
call escalation dead misses a call
escalation i'm talking about dad in jail
or dad who's divorced who just is kind
of flaky
and so at some point
i'm not gonna let this person who is
their biological father but they are is
not daddy
i'm not gonna let this person
continue to throw grenades inside my
house at some point i'm the parent i
gotta draw boundaries similar to this
electronic mass okay
moms and dads you've heard me if you're
listening to the show for five seconds
you've heard me and i'll say it again
and i'll say it again and i'll say it
again
at some point we have to stand up in our
local schools and stand up in our local
communities and say enough is enough
with the electronics as a taxpayer
the pedagogical value is just
dismal the roi on the amount of money
we're spending
in public schools and local schools
private schools i don't care just to say
look what we have look what we have look
what we have
when it comes to technological
advancements you can see the state of
teachers may i just go off we got to
stop we have to stop we have to stop
somebody has to fight for their kids
please let it be you
please let it be you